trois statues royales mi homme mi animal
trésor du royaume du dahomey actuel
bénin
elles datent du 19e siècle et ont été
ramenées en france par l'armée coloniale
du général zod un butin de guerre
aujourd'hui exposée au musée du quai
branly à paris
comme ces masques et ses portes du
palais du roi béhanzin des codes comme
un rébus une histoire et des oeuvres
d'art que connaît bien marie cécile
zinsou un caméléon qui elle s'envole du
roi akaba cette béninoise meliet depuis
une douzaine d'années pour que ces
pièces retournent dans leur pays
d'origine
je pense que ces objets sont qui est que
c'est écrit c'est prouvé c'est voilà
c'est un pillage qui a mieux prendre une
guerre je pense que ces oeuvres sont
légitimes dans le voyage de retour
ces efforts viennent d'être couronnés de
succès suivant les conclusions d'une
étude qu'il a commandé le président
macron annoncé récemment la restitution
de 26 oeuvres réclamée par le bénin
les auteurs du rapport recommandent à la
france de modifier ses lois pour
faciliter la restitution de milliers
d'oeuvres africaine arrivé en france
pendant la période coloniale
ce que met en exergue le rapport c'est
l'extrême déséquilibre qui existe
alors que la presque totalité du
patrimoine culturel africain se trouvent
dans des musées en europe
le musée du quai branly par exemple à
paris quant à lui seul plus de 70 mille
oeuvres d'origine africaine mais la
restitution est loin de faire
l'unanimité dans le mot restitution il y
à un concept de culpabilité et de
possession illégitime et ça c'est un
vrai problème on ce commissaire priseur
spécialisé dans l'art africain estime
qu'il faudrait pouvoir prouver que des
oeuvres ont été acquises de façon
illégale avant de penser à les rendre je
pense que 90% du marché actuel n'a pas
été pillé et dérobé
mais il ya été d'une part troqué données
achetées etc mais surtout préserver
selon lui son pays n'a pas à se sentir
coupable
sur ces oeuvres auraient sans doute
disparu la france ne les avaient pas
préserver la regarder la city pic des
termites d argument que réfute marie
cécile zinsou
si une étape importante vient d'être
franchie l'historienne de l'art
béninoise se garde bien de crier
victoire tant que les agents soient
présentés au public pour se féliciter
pour féliciter ou attendre des actes
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
paris